[Music]
the eu's forests are at risk
help us protect them forests are a
cornerstone of biodiversity and climate
protection however eu forests are
deteriorating
up to 84
protected forests are in unfavorable or
inadequate status
the resilience of eu forest is
threatened by forest fires
and sustainable forestry practices and
the increasing impact of invasive alien
species
resulting in rapid biodiversity loss
moreover climate change adds to these
threats and creates additional pressures
this is why we need a common action to
protect eu forests the eu's key
challenges in forest management are
related to mainstreaming sustainable
forestry practices sustainable
consumption patterns
recycling and recovery of wood products
[Music]
forests are also crucial for green
growth and economy because they mitigate
greenhouse gas emissions
enhance energy and resource efficiency
and prevent biodiversity loss the eu is
addressing these challenges through
various actions
such as the european green deal
the eu foreign strategy and the eu
biodiversity strategy for 2030
the eu green deal aims to improve the
quality and quantity of eu forests
by using a comprehensive approach it
applies to several services provided by
forests
such as climate
biodiversity
bio-based circular economy and social
and cultural services
[Music]
the eu green deal also sets objectives
on air forestation forest preservation
and restoration
there are four eu key forest commitments
in the biodiversity strategy
one
define map monitor and strictly protect
remaining eu primary and old growth
forests
two
develop guidelines on biodiversity
friendly afforestation reforestation
and closer to nature forestry practices
three plant three billion trees by 2030
in line with ecological principles
4 produce up-to-date assessments of the
condition of european forests
forests are irreplaceable reservoirs of
biodiversity and require urgent
protection
now is the time to act
[Music]